y el anuncio de un futbolista checo de
qué se trata Andrés estamos hablando de
Jacob llanto que es ahora mismo el
jugador de más alto perfil en anunciar
públicamente su homosexualidad tiene 27
años es centrocampista del Sparta de
Praga préstamo por el getafe español y
dio esta noticia a través de sus redes
sociales ya Cómo ha sido internacional
en 45 ocasiones con su selección
República Checa y disputó la pasada
Eurocopa asegura que quiere vivir en
libertad escuchemos
como todos los demás Yo también quiero
vivir mi vida con libertad sin miedo sin
prejuicios sin violencia pero con amor
Soy homosexual y ya no me quiero
esconder más
recordemos que anuncios de este tipo son
muy poco frecuentes en el fútbol de
élite masculino pero recientemente ha
habido otros casos conocidos el caso del
australiano quien en 2021 se convirtió
en el primer futbolista de una liga de
primer nivel y en anunciar que es gay el
año pasado fue Jack daños del blackbull
de la Segunda División inglesa el que
dio a conocer que es homosexual y
cuéntanos cómo ha reaccionado el mundo
del fútbol a esta noticia Andrés desde
el espartade de ese club de Jacob hasta
la propia UEFA y en particular las ligas
de España y la Premier de Inglaterra han
expresado su apoyo al anuncio de yaku al
respecto habló incluso Neymar el
delantero brasileño a quien se le
preguntó por el tema en la previa ese
partido de Champions contra el Bayern de
Múnich escuchemos
No creo que cada uno es libre y no tenga
un problema con ello
no tengo prejuicios y todas las formas
de discriminación homofobia racismo
necesitan ser reducidas en todas las
áreas creo que cada quien debería
sentirse libre y ser capaz de ser
espontáneo con lo que quieren hacer